Yahoo welcome to this video and this is
the first video of a little serious than
it's going to start here yeah one week
of opening challenges yeah I've accepted
this challenge quite some weeks ago and
it's only yeah i mean with weeks ago
from the actual release date of this
video and it's about playing different
opening so I'm not allowed for one week
to play 1d4 related openings and with I
have to go for something else in default
and what I also have to do is with black
I have to avoid a couple of things so
know who lopez's is black and things
like that so it's quite funny I'm I'm
going for you for because one part of
the challenge is to play the pond siani
a couple of times which is andrina with
it which is even more difficult so kind
of a kind of funny okay um can I go look
he won moh three okay Bishop g4 it's not
a big deal I want to play Bishop e3 here
trying to trade this off let's try that
if i get rid of this bishop would be
nice this b6 bishop yeah what we got
here by transposition is something that
closely resembles a french tirage why
plays an entire iqp game here Black's d5
pawn is slide weakness but on the other
hand um he has very active pieces so
it's not not like black as much mercy or
anything I so let's see it's pinger this
ping if this pin is quite annoying I
wonder maybe I should just drop back
here and make sure that I'm breaking
this pin by the h5 bishop if he goes
Knight f-5e I go Bishop c5 yeah queen d
60 this is
possibility I thought 94 might be
something I can also play Bishop c5 by
the way it's not it stopped and then I'm
getting checkmated there quickly yeah
maybe if he goes to f4 I have Queen d2
which gets me close to trait and
generally I would like to trade him with
this strategic asset of the iqp that I
can play against yeah the opening
challenge quite fun also I can bears
black f to avoid nims oh and bogo and on
my usual stuff so it would be really
funny so I'm going to try to get Queen
strategy it's not easy for him to to
avoid that now ok you can go queen of
six but I have Queen g5 if everything
else fails i can go Queen g5 and really
force the trade so cringy 5 or not yeah
let's do that it's really that seems ok
I mean I'm trading and this is trading
is really ok here so if I go Bishop to
b5 attacking this night there are only
seven what then rook e8 looks a bit bit
tricky
hmm not sure if it is so so helpful
actually I'd like to move this bishop
and attack the night down but it's no no
real good good square to go to Bishop b5
rupee a it seems ok maybe 90 for them
mmm that's actually a point that's
actually a point a 94 it looks quite
active night XD for can I just icky
eight hmm maybe Jim hey Scott this is
quite under some pressure now they're on
one c6 c7 and so on can i txt for this
is possible 94 Bishop e8 night see to
tell but I can I can take on aid ok so
he just drops back there
can't even take e5 but not sure if this
is doing much Bishop c6 9696 not doing
much surprising well this is still kind
of okay do I want to take only five not
clear not clear to me yeah maybe let's
let's try that it's it's it's more like
trading thing but I have rookie one now
and he's in a bit of an awkward pin so i
thought this might be interesting
now I cannot just go knight c6 as you
spin then even like 96 f 4 as a move
okay my e 1 book is also unprotected so
tricky if he goes f6 what am I going to
play yeah I thought f form but he might
have f6 might have six them f1 idea
three uncovered if i take c 6 first job
that's it's not that much
it's not that much it's not it's not bad
here but it's not that much f4 and you
can attack the night now now if the Pawn
down can march all the way to e7 not
sure if this is how much this is worth
ok it's nice i can add it with the pawn
is very obstructing actually can walk
all the way over here to default and
even further the aligned one is going to
win now i am winning a piece Bishop f 78
queen for promoter promoting yeah and i
can go here now check and now for a
full-scale invasion now ok just going to
promote the pawn black resign yeah that
looked ok first the first game of the
challenge with one hit for we worked out
fine let's briefly look at this this is
a good repertoire actually that I quite
often recommend to students and there's
a sayin if you don't want to play very
heavy theory just go 93 after you six
you go see 3 which is a somewhat um more
manageable version of the c3 the
Sicilian because with this diagonal now
blocked black cam has faded some of its
his answers he's not in trouble or
anything but it's just easier to learn
that to c3 and after d6 and champion I'm
advocating the check and of course he as
well Bishop b5 those are good good lines
that can be played without too much
knowledge and here this son this line
also is quite quite playable without
them knowing too much too much theory ok
wanted to trade that which he avoided no
yeah maybe Bishop c5 immediately but I
wanted to break that pin and I don't
know if have something we forgot
something better ok g3 is the comp line
I don't think this is bad though just
trade Queens yeah this is a bit bit bit
crude but probably strong actually I
because I'm training his best defensive
Peter come gives me a pretty clear idea
form there should be five and now I did
something stupid ok I could have taken
e7 now that's actually quite easy that's
quite easy you know here this is a very
very winning position and if he does
that can go here yeah and I'm keeping
this Bishop so that was a very simple
win actually so badly played here f6 I
wondered about h6 yeah maybe this is
probably good right I can do this but
this is just probably yeah yeah not sure
this is a draw opposite colored bishops
but this is a very outside pawn that
might be not that easy to draw here here
here I think where I went I didn't take
the pawn I think II six is just stronger
I have to get the pawn down to e7 so
here and okay look everyone is even
stronger but I think I think this should
be good for wine it really should be
good for white this is probably not a
great idea but i don't know how i c-cut
an obvious account check my my invasion
don't really see see how it's going to
be holding here with the depot and there
are only seven okay well thanks for
watching